all right
all right all right bang bang
what's going on everyone uh we're gonna
wait a couple minutes as people start to
trickle in
today we're gonna be talking about
bitcoin
what is it how does it work why is it
important
and how does it fit into the global
macro economy
before we get started please smash the
like button
subscribe to the channel and if you like
all of this content you can go to
pompletter.com
i've left the url in the chat i write a
daily email
where you can get that every single
morning in your inbox
so smash the like button subscribe to
the channel let's get
into it uh first let's start with what
is
bitcoin simply i'm gonna explain all
this in
a very generalized manner think of this
as kind of bitcoin 101 and it will kind
of graduate to higher levels of
understanding
and what i'm going to try to do here is
use very plain
english and very concise explanation so
what is bitcoin
bitcoin is digital money and in order to
understand bitcoin we first have to
start with
what is money and money has two
properties
it is a store of value and it is a
medium of exchange
and if you go all the way back to
ancient roman times
every single money has served as a store
value and a medium of exchange
now ultimately the things that have
served as money
have evolved throughout the years so we
had everything from
uh precious metals to seashells
to paper claims on commodities all kinds
of different things
but at the end of the day money is a
belief system
right especially in a fiat world if you
think of the us dollar
it is simply the belief between two
people that
that thing that is being transacted that
dollar that is being exchanged for a
good or service
has value if the two parties do not
believe that it has value
then it is not money because it cannot
be used if both parties believe then it
is money
so that is what money ultimately is
money is a belief system
and what we've seen is it serves as a
store value and a medium of exchange
and so bitcoin is merely digital money
if you think back uh before the internet
there was all sorts of analog
businesses when the internet came along
we simply took
the idea of those analog businesses and
we put it
on the internet we made some changes we
improved things
we made some tweaks but what we did was
we took business that existed in the
analog world and we put it on the
internet we digitized the business
what bitcoin is is bitcoin is taking the
idea or concept of money
and it is just digitizing or putting it
into
the digital world now we've made a lot
of improvements we've made a lot of
tweaks to
um kind of existing money to bitcoin but
that's ultimately what we're talking
about it is simply digital money
and so how does bitcoin work
bitcoin works off of the same exact
concept
that monopoly works on so what i'd like
to talk about
is bitcoin uses a transparent public
ledger and those are big fancy words
that people use to try to sound smart
but what exactly is a transparent
public ledger it's simply if you were
playing monopoly
and you have four people sitting down in
front of the board game everybody
sets up the board you take the money and
you put it out in front of you on the
table
and then there's a bank and that bank is
a collection of all of the money that's
not in an individual's
um you know in front of them on the
board and the reason why
there's only four people who are playing
monopoly but you don't have a banker
is because there's full transparency in
the game
so if i roll the dice and i pass go i
reach in the bank and i take 200
everyone at the table can see that i
took the 200
and i put it in my bank if all of a
sudden i buy a property or somebody buys
one of my properties
the exchange of funds at the game is all
done publicly and transparently for
everyone to see
because it's public and transparent
during the game of monopoly there's no
need for a
third party or some sort of
authoritative figure right when you're
kids you don't need your parents to sit
over you and say
okay johnny give the 200 it's just known
that the four players that table can
can understand because of the public
transparent system now
in the legacy fiat system right in the
legacy finance system
almost every single transaction that
occurs whether it is with money or other
financial assets
there is a centralized third party all
that means
is if i want to do a transaction with
you i take the asset that i have
and i go to give it to you but i can't
give it directly to you
i have to give it to somebody else who
gives it to you
they process the transaction and so
ultimately what you and i are doing when
we enter into a transaction or an
agreement
is we are trusting that that centralized
third party
is going to do what we want them to do
but in some cases
they don't do what we want them to do
they may go rogue
they could steal they could do something
that they
claim that we don't fit their profile so
they don't want to process the
transaction
all kinds of different things but one of
the points of failure
in the legacy system is that we have to
trust this
third party this centralized system
bitcoin
one of the improvements it made was the
public transparent ledger
and that public transparent ledger meant
that nobody
had to trust a centralized third party i
now can transact directly with you
across the bitcoin network and no one or
nothing
can stop us from transacting it is a
fully decentralized system decentralized
just means nobody's in control
so a lot of people when they hear that
the bitcoin system is decentralized and
no one's in control
the first question is well how does that
work so
essentially what is going on is bitcoin
was launched on january 3rd
2009 and when it was launched every
single transaction that has ever
happened
is on a public ledger if you go back to
the monopoly game it would be like every
time there was money trading hands
either from the bank to a player
or from player to player there was one
of the players sitting there
and they wrote down the transaction so
johnny gave sarah 200
and they wrote it down on a piece of
paper on the next line sarah gave
anthony a hundred dollars right
and every single transaction just got
written down but after
10 minutes of playing we said wait a
second
rip off that piece of paper from the the
notebook
and put it to the side that would then
start
us writing down the transactions for the
second 10 minutes
of the game and if every 10 minutes we
ripped off the piece of paper and simply
stacked it on
the last piece of paper at the end of
the game we would have an entire pile of
paper
where we could go back and we could look
at every single transaction that
happened in the monopoly game
and we could even go to the exact time
so if we said hey
between 7 10 p.m and 7 20 p.m
i think i gave you uh 300 we could go
back in the transactions and we could
find
710 to 720 and we could find that exact
transaction written down
that's what the bitcoin blockchain does
and that's a very over generalized uh
example but ultimately what the bitcoin
blockchain does
is every single transaction that happens
in about
a 10-minute block gets written down
digitally
and then it gets blocked together so
there's a block
right or a group of these transactions
and it's kind of tied up in a 10-minute
block
and then that block is tied to or
connected to the last 10 minute block so
the bitcoin
block chain is simply a chain
of blocks that hold transactions in them
and each block contains about 10 minutes
worth of transactions
and they're all just chained together so
the 10 minutes that's occurring right
now
when it's over we will take all the
transactions that happen in that 10
minute period
and we're going to chain it to the last
10 minutes and you can go
all the way back to january 3rd 2009
and you can see every single transaction
that's occurred so
part of the beauty of this system is not
only that nobody
owns it nobody controls it but also
that anyone in the world can go and see
every single transaction right again
it's a
fully public transparent system and so
this entire idea of bitcoin
is built on something uh that'll that
people refer to as trustless
and what that means is you don't have to
trust the system
you don't have to trust a centralized
third party you actually don't even need
to trust
the person that you're transacting with
everything that you need to do
you can verify right there you can go
and find the truth
and what i mean by that is when i send a
wire at a bank
i'm trusting that the bank's not going
to take my money that the bank is
actually going to give it to the right
person
and that the bank or the recipient's
bank is going to accept the money
so i'm trusting multiple parties in that
transaction
here i don't have to trust anybody to
send it
i don't have to trust anybody's bank to
receive it and i can actually go
verify that the money was sent right the
bitcoin was sent
and i can verify who received it how
much
and i can even see what they do with it
and so when you kind of go through this
system it is a public transparent system
that is not owned by anybody it's fully
decentralized and so
a lot of people will say okay well how
is that run
how does the transactions get processed
if you're processing transactions
you need some sort of computing power to
do that
you're right it's in the bitcoin system
there's something called
bitcoin mining and you can think of the
miners
all they are doing is they are
processing transactions right
they are there to run the bitcoin
software in a very generalized manner
and what i mean by that is they
essentially have specialized computers
that are very high computing power and
they run the bitcoin software and they
process transactions
and they're financially incentivized to
do this how are they financially
incentivized
well there's only 21 million bitcoin so
there's an artificial supply there will
never be more than 21 million bitcoin
and in the beginning starting in 2009
every 10 minutes 50 bitcoin were
released
to everybody who was running the
software
so that 50 bitcoin that was released in
the first 10 minutes went to
everybody who was running the software
now not every single person got 50
bitcoin
but it was split up among everyone
running the software and so the next 20
minutes
or the next 10 minute block so it's kind
of 10 to 20 minutes
now everyone running the software got
access to 50 bitcoin right and it got
split among everyone running it
and so that has continued since 2009
all the way up until today but the one
thing that happened
in the bitcoin system was that it was
programmatically designed for that 50
bitcoin per 10 minutes that's called the
bitcoin reward
that 50 bitcoin per 10 minutes gets cut
in half
every four years so it started out at 50
bitcoin
every 10 minutes for four years 50
bitcoin was distributed to everyone who
was running the network
after four years it got cut to 25
bitcoin then for four years in a row
25 bitcoin was given to every single
miner for four years that happened and
then it got cut to 12 and a half
and so every 10 minutes for another four
years 12 and a half
in may of 2020 it just got cut from 12
and a half to 6.25 million
or 6.25 bitcoin and so that 6.25 bitcoin
is distributed to miners every 10
minutes that is their financial
incentive to run the bitcoin software
and process the transactions
the beauty is that you can actually find
truth one of two ways you can either
rely on a centralized third party
they're in charge they're the authority
they have all the power
and they tell all of the participants in
a market what is true and what is not
if the bank says that you did something
then you did it if the bank says you
didn't do it then you didn't do it
you have no way to tell the bank
anything right if all of a sudden the
bank
uh you went to the atm tomorrow and the
bank said nope you don't have five
thousand dollars in your account now you
only have a thousand
how would you prove that you had five
thousand dollars
right it's a centralized party they have
control that's where the risk is
so one way to get to quote unquote truth
is to have a central party tell people
what the truth is
the other way to find truth is to have
consensus
among 51 or more of a very
decentralized distributed network and
that's what the bitcoin system does
the bitcoin system has millions of nodes
all around the world completely
geographically distributed
and they all work together to find the
truth right to process the transactions
and determine truth
and so that is the beauty of the bitcoin
system is that it is fully decentralized
fully distributed
and it doesn't rely on any centralized
third party
so why is this system important
today we have two financial systems
we have the legacy finance system
that relies on a fiat currency the us
dollar
as the core unit of account and that
core unit of account
has a monetary policy that is
inflationary in nature
meaning that they constantly produce
more of it and it devalues over time
since the early 1900s the u.s dollar has
lost 95 plus percent of its purchasing
power right
so what one dollar could buy a hundred
years ago
is much much more than what one dollar
could buy today so you need many more
dollars to buy the same
amount of goods or services that you
needed 100 years ago that's because it's
inflationary in nature
bitcoin is a 180 degree opposite
so the second financial system or the
alternative financial system or what
people call the bitcoin system or the
digital finance system
is all based on a deflationary asset
and all again big fancy finance word all
that means is
there's a capped amount there's only 21
million bitcoin
about 18.4 million bitcoin have already
been
put into circulation through that
bitcoin reward that we talked about that
mechanism
and so there's still about just about
two and a half
million bitcoin that are going to be
distributed over the coming years and
decades
and so in a deflationary system what
that means is that
the asset the core unit of account a
bitcoin
or um a fraction of a bitcoin will
continue to
increase in value rather than decrease
because
supply and demand economics tell us if
you have a fixed supply of an asset
and demand increases then the only thing
that can happen
is you could either try to produce more
of the asset
or the price has to go up because
bitcoin can't be recreated no one's
producing more bitcoin
that means that the price continues to
rise bitcoin has grown in us dollar
terms
at a compound annual growth rate of over
30 percent
for many many years now and so the
deflationary nature or
structure and design of bitcoin is 180
degrees difference it's the complete
opposite of the inflationary fiat system
that we all have had grown up using now
bitcoin because it's still um injecting
new supply right there's still a daily
incoming supply there's 900 bitcoin per
day that are put into circulation that
are new to the system
there's only 21 million total but the
circulating supply gains 900 a day right
now
that means it is a disinflationary
system
or a disinflationary monetary supply all
of that means again big fancy words
in plain english that means that you've
got a certain amount of bitcoin
that's created every day before may of
2020 that was
1800 bitcoin it got cut in half now it's
900
in four years it'll get cut in half
again and it'll go from 900 to 450.
so dis means it's going down
inflationary means you're adding some to
the circulating supply
so it's a disinflationary monetary
supply schedule
that is built in a deflationary monetary
structure or design
and so bitcoin being a deflationary
structure and complete opposite of the
fiat system
provides an alternative historically
every single money in the world every
single money
was a fiat currency which meant that if
you go back to
money right in the legacy sense of it
we've used
commodities for money for a long time so
take gold for example
gold was used on coins and bars of gold
to buy goods and services for trade
for barter all of those things it's very
hard to carry around it's heavy
it's very hard to divide it it's not
very divisible right in terms of you got
to shave it off and things like that
and so what we ultimately came up with
was we said gold
is really really secure right we know
where the gold is because i can hold the
gold in my hand it's heavy it's hard to
produce all these things
but it's hard to actually use for
transactions so we created
paper claims on the gold those were
in the dollar system dollars those
dollars
were merely you could go exchange a
dollar to get gold back
right they were interchangeable you just
had a paper claim to the gold and the
gold sat in a vault somewhere
so it was much easier to use the dollars
to transact
then actually use the gold but 1971
we decided in a temporary measure at the
time
to break from the gold standard to say
you no longer can take your dollars
and turn them in for gold the dollars
are not backed by anything
and so this was the rise of the fiat
currency experiment
fiat simply just means it's not backed
by a a commodity it's just a piece of
paper
and so in the current system today what
we have is we have a money system
that is determined by in the united
states the federal reserve and other
countries the central banks
and that money is a belief system we all
believe it has value right i use dollars
everyone here probably uses dollars as
well
and that money has become the global
reserve currency
it's backed by the strongest military in
the world it's backed by the greatest
economy in the world in terms of the
united states and
you know post-industrial revolution all
these things so that is what has given
it value
is the belief that it has value but as
we have seen in many many other
countries around the world
if it gets devalued too quickly because
you can produce more of it if a country
loses discipline
that currency can be uh the faith in
that currency or the belief in that
currency
can be lost by the citizens so if you
look in places like lebanon right now
in venezuela zimbabwe other countries in
history
what you find is that the currency gets
devalued so quickly
that all of a sudden people say wait a
second i'm actually
losing money because i need way more of
this currency to buy the same goods and
services
that i needed yesterday so obviously the
currency is worth less money
and therefore i need to get out of it
and so ultimately the the belief system
breaks down
and people flee a currency and they go
into other assets whether that's gold
another fiat currency whatever it is
the beauty of the design of bitcoin is
that it is
not inflationary you cannot produce more
and therefore rather than it
lose value over time like a fiat
currency it actually
gains value in time as long as demand
continues to increase and so
again for over a decade demand has not
only continued to increase it's
continued to increase at a very very
fast pace
and so for the first time in history
what we have
is we have two financial systems we've
got the legacy finance
system that uses the dollar as the base
unit of account that's an inflationary
currency
we also have an alternative financial
system that has a digital
decentralized currency as its core unit
of account which is bitcoin
and it is deflationary in nature meaning
that it's not going to have more made of
it
now many of you are saying wait a minute
there's only 21 million bitcoin
how could everyone in the world only use
21 million bitcoin well
bitcoin is highly divisible right so you
can divide it up
you can actually go and buy just a
couple of
uh pennies worth of bitcoin right you
don't have to buy a full bitcoin which
today is
uh about eleven thousand dollars you can
go buy ten dollars of a bitcoin
you could buy fifty dollars a hundred
dollars five hundred 500 of a bitcoin
right you don't have to only have a full
bitcoin you can get a fraction of one
and the way that those are talked about
or measured is in something called a
satoshi
now satoshi is there's 100 million
satoshi's
per bitcoin right so if you think about
100 million
or satoshi's per one bitcoin and then
there's 21 million bitcoin
now what you will hear people talk about
is 10 000 satoshi's
right that is a equivalent to
pennies in the fiat system so you've got
bitcoin that's a full
bitcoin and then you've got uh satoshi's
that are fractional
shares or fractional percentages of a
full bitcoin
and so now all of a sudden you have a
system that looks very similar to the
fiat system right you can use a hundred
dollar bill
or you can use a 20 bill or you can use
a one dollar bill or you can use
pennies dimes nickels quarters etcetera
so same thing here is you can have a
full bitcoin right again is equal to
about 11 000 u.s dollars
or you could have a very small percent
you could have
four or five satoshis you could have ten
thousand satoshis you could have a
hundred thousand satoshis a million
satoshis right there's a hundred million
satoshis per bitcoin
so why is this important historically
if you did not believe that a fiat
currency was going to
serve you best doesn't mean it has to
fail but just you didn't feel like that
served you best
you had no other option other than to go
to
gold which again is not a great way to
transact as a medium of exchange
or you had to go to another fiat
currency
so if you didn't want fiat currency
there was no way to kind of opt out
of this legacy uh finance system now
with bitcoin there's a way to actually
opt out of the system
and so what millions of people have
chosen to do is take some percent
of their net worth doesn't mean that
it's a lot could be only one percent
could be 50
right anywhere in there they've chosen
to take some percent of their net worth
and opt out of the legacy finance system
and
buy bitcoin and use that as their new
core unit of account
so in their head they don't price things
in dollars
they will actually price them in bitcoin
so for example if i want to buy let's
say a new phone
i could say okay that is 1200 u.s
dollars polina's back there says hello
to everybody
hi guys so that is 1200 us dollars
if to buy a computer but if i want to
pay for it in bitcoin
i could think to myself and say wait a
second that is
10 million satoshi's right or 15 million
satoshi's and therefore that's how i'm
gonna pay the denominator or what the
the asset is denominated in ends up
being bitcoin rather than dollars
and so ultimately this is a
a separation of a legacy system and an
alternative system
one has the dollar and other fiat
currencies as their core unit of account
the other the digital decentralized
system has bitcoin as the core unit of
account
and so when you look at what's happening
in the world
we continue to see governments devalue
their currencies and they do that
through quantitative easing
so if you look at kind of the macro
environment
what occurs at the macro environment is
uh the exact same thing
all across the world a government
creates money at their central bank they
then
when there is a market downturn or
there's some kind of issue in the
economy
they sit there and they say well we
couldn't let the free market
determine what happens here but actually
if we step in if we start to
intervene and maybe we just give
ourselves a little jolt we could print a
little money we could drop interest
rates or we could kind of manipulate the
economy
we can get high again and so it's very
similar to the econ
the economy is very similar to a drug
addict if you're a crack addict
there was a point where you were sober
you'd never tried crack before you try
for the first time and you get high
you like it you want to get high again
so you take more crack
you get high a second time you like it
again every time that you take
crack you've got to take more and more
to get the same high
right it becomes less effective as a
drugs it take more and more and
ultimately if you take too much
you literally overdose and you die well
economies are no different
there was a time period where there was
no monetary stimulus there's no
quantitative easing there was no
intervention by the government
but as we started to intervene and print
money and inject this quantitative
easing and monetary stimulus
we became addicted to that stimulus
it was like an adrenaline uh punch right
like oh man
every time we do that everything goes up
and everyone would say wait a second if
asset prices are going up the economy is
great let's do that again
and so the two last examples in 2008 we
saw this
asset prices sold off in the summer of
2008 the government stepped in they
printed hundreds of billions of dollars
and when they printed hundreds of
billions of dollars what happened was
all of the asset prices stopped falling
from the liquidity crisis
and they all recovered and then rallied
so something like gold for example
dropped 30 over the summer of 2008 and
then the government started to print
money
and then gold went up more than 200
percent and hit an all-time high of
1900 in 2011. well
they in this most recent uh economic
recession
have used the same playbook there was a
global pandemic there was a healthcare
crisis or a virus
that led to government saying we are
going to shut down local state and
federal economies
right our national economies and that
slows the velocity of money
so investors then enter into this
liquidity crisis
they want dollars but they have assets
so they need to sell the assets so they
can get dollars
and they look around their portfolio and
say what has a liquid market what can i
sell
and they start selling assets and
there's so many people selling that the
prices are dropping
and the dollar is strengthening right if
you think about
every single price you think of so gold
stocks
bitcoin whatever there are two numbers
that determine that price
it think take bitcoin one btc over
how many dollars right same thing with
stocks
how much one share over how what is the
us dollar price what is the ratio or the
the exchange of price there
i'm willing to buy or sell one share of
apple
at x price of dollars so when all of the
asset prices sell off
what actually happens is the dollar is
strengthening and asset prices are
dropping
it takes less dollars to buy the same
good or service right because the dollar
is stronger so i need less dollars to
buy the same good or service
well the government in 2009 and then
again uh
in the last couple of months says wait a
second we can stop this
all we need to do to stop asset prices
from dropping
and to stabilize markets and have them
go back to recover is let's just
flood the market with money right so
they go and they
create uh in the most recent uh
situation they've created trillions of
dollars of monetary stimulus and
quantitative easing
and they start giving it into the market
and injecting it into the economy
they do that through loans they do that
through stimulus checks
they do that through unemployment checks
they do that through
all sorts of bailouts like there's a
multitude of ways and very exotic ways
that they get this money into the
economy
when they do that what happened was
asset prices stopped going down equities
had gone down 30 percent gold had gone
down
12 to 15 percent bitcoin had gone down
50
right um treasury everything had sold
off
when they flooded the market with
dollars all of a sudden
all the asset prices rised and so take
stocks for example those have rallied
off the bottom
of the march uh price bottom 50 plus
percent
well why in a economic recession where
many of those companies have
lost 50 60 70 80 90
of their revenue have they uh absolutely
exploded in value
go back to their priced in dollars it's
not that the stock is getting more
valuable
it's that the dollar is weakening so
it's now gonna take
because the dollar is worth less you
need more dollars to buy the same asset
so go to to a traditional stock let's
say a stock was a hundred dollars before
the pandemic started
well when everything started to sell off
the stock now you only needed 50
to buy the same stock right so i needed
less dollars to buy that same one share
of a company
so 50 to buy the same share that i
needed i used to need 100
by the same share now once they flooded
the market and there's dollars
everywhere
now i don't need fifty dollars i don't
need a hundred dollars
i need a hundred and fifty dollars to
buy that same stock
it's because the dollar is getting worth
less and less they're devaluing the
currency
now why is that important and this is
kind of the the big
issue with fiat currencies and
inflationary type
systems is that there is a very big
difference
in how inflation impacts the top fifty
percent of a population
and the bottom fifty percent of a
population so when we print money
and cause inflation the argument is if
you know that your currency is going to
be worth less
a year two three four five years from
now it's gonna lose value over time
you're going to be incentivized not to
hold on to that uh money
and you're gonna be financially
incentivized to go spend it or go buy
assets so you're going to increase the
velocity of money right how fast do you
turn the money over well if i know it's
losing value i don't want to hold it
so let me either go give it to somebody
for a good or service or let me give it
to somebody so that i can get an ass and
an exchange right and then you keep
money moving around in the system
that's the argument for an inflationary
system well the problem is
that system is built on 50 percent
of americans not understanding how money
works
50 of americans don't understand what i
just said
they don't realize that their dollars
are going to be worth less
next year and the year after in the year
after the year after so what they do is
they hold the dollars
right the bottom 50 of the u.s
population
holds their dollars they live paycheck
to paycheck
and they just simply save in cash
everything that they have is in cash
50 i think it's 45 percent of americans
do not own a stock so they own no stocks
no investment assets
almost 50 percent of americans couldn't
come up with 400
for an emergency payment which means
that these people are living
paycheck to paycheck in all cash no
investment assets
but if i save a hundred dollars in the
bank today
and that hundred dollars could go back
and buy one share of let's just use
apple stock for as an example even
though it's obviously more than a
hundred dollars
if i save a hundred dollars in my bank
today and it could buy me one apple
share
but i wait till next year or the year
after the year after and i've left it in
cash the whole time
now i'm gonna need much more than a
hundred dollars to buy that same apple
share
simply because my dollars are worth less
the purchasing power has been eroded
away
and so what ultimately happens is the
bottom fifty percent of americans
they constantly have this feeling like i
can't get ahead i'm always falling
behind
i just can't get ahead but it's because
they haven't been educated on how money
in the economy works
so they simply just hold cash and when
they hold cash
and there's high levels of inflation
they're the ones who get hurt the most
because if all of your wealth is just
sitting in cash
it's losing purchasing power right the
second way that the bottom fifty percent
of americans get hurt through inflation
is the fact that most people in the
service industry in the hospitality
industry right hourly workers whatever
they do not have something called an
inflation-adjusted wage contract
all that means is that if you get paid
ten dollars an hour
to this year and you get paid ten
dollars an hour next year and the year
after the year after
you think i'm getting paid ten dollars
now i'm getting paid the same amount of
money
but in terms of your purchasing power
you're actually getting paid
less every single year right rich people
they don't get paid the same amount
every year their
salary goes up it's an inflation
adjustment
it goes up two to three percent every
single year to mitigate the impact of
inflation
so it makes sure that they are at least
going to get paid the same in purchasing
power
um every single year if not more the
bottom fifty percent they get
crushed by this they do not get the
protection
and so what ends up happening is they
make less and less money over time
even though it looks like they're still
making that ten dollars an hour so the
bottom fifty percent
get absolutely destroyed by inflation
the poor get
poorer why are rich people okay with
this
well because this is how rich people get
rich right
the inflationary nature of the economy
makes rich get richer
and poor get poor what happens to the
rich people the rich people know how
money works
they understand if i hold cash that cash
is going to be less
uh worth less over time so i am
financially incentivized to spend it
on goods and services or i should take
the money and i should go buy investment
assets so what do rich people do they
don't have a lot of cash
they go and they buy stocks they buy
commodities they buy art they buy homes
they buy
bitcoin they buy all kinds of assets and
they know that over a very long period
of time
because the dollar is getting devalued
it will take more dollars to buy the
same asset
right if you bought a house in 1980 and
you held it to today
it is very likely that that house is
worth more money
than it was in 1980 but is that because
the house
became better or is that because the
dollar devalued and maybe it was a 50
000 house in 1980 but now it's a 200 000
house in 2020 and it's just the fact
that you the dollar got devalued and so
you need to buy
uh you need more dollars to buy that
same house well rich people know the
game so they don't hold cash and they
get investment assets right
they get into assets that continue to go
up so they continue to get richer
as inflation happens while poor people
get crushed and they end up getting
poorer over time now when we print lots
of
money normally that leads to higher
levels of inflation
so if we just print the traditional
amount or the historic kind of average
of money
there's about one and a half to two
percent inflation every year there's a
two percent inflation target
right well when we start to print
trillions and trillions of dollars
one of the fears that people have is
that we will not only see two percent
inflation
we'll see something more than two
percent right
and if we see more than two percent in
the official inflation numbers
that means that the poor are getting
punished even more
and the rich are getting richer and
richer so look what's happened over the
last couple of months
the billionaires in the united states
have made
collectively almost half a trillion
dollars
over the last couple of months how could
that be when
50 plus million americans have lost
their jobs and there's a global pandemic
and tens of millions of small businesses
in america are gonna get shut down
and we're in a recession yet the rich
people made half a trillion dollars
it's because majority of their net worth
is in
assets not in cash and those assets
have continued to increase in price
because the dollar is being devalued by
all the money we're printing
so it's not that the rich people did
anything necessarily different they
simply are
they understand the game they know the
rules of money they
understand how to build wealth and they
have positioned themselves
to get wealthy over a long period of
time rather than
hold cash and see their wealth
constantly eroded away by inflation
so that's how the traditional macro
economy works right that's how inflation
works
now what does this have to do with
bitcoin why is this important
bitcoin protects people's wealth and
what i mean by that is
if bitcoin is the core unit of account
there is no inflation
right there is no ability for somebody
to go create
tons more of bitcoin and erode away the
value of bitcoin
right there's no printing press when it
comes to bitcoin so rather than be
financially incentivized
to get out of the currency and to have
to go buy investment assets
you now can go from having to be an
investor to simply being a
saver so in the legacy finance system
investors win and savers lose right
that's very important
in the dollar based system investors win
and savers lose in the bitcoin or the
alternative financial system that this
digital decentralized system
savers win because they're saving in an
asset that is deflationary it's
artificial right
the same thing like in the u.s dollar
system where buying land
they're not making more land so you can
buy land and the dollar will devalue and
your land will become more valuable as
more people want land
the same thing here they're not making
more bitcoin there's 21 million of them
that will ever be available
and the way that people value bitcoin
is in terms of u.s dollars so when you
hold bitcoin
as part of a portfolio what happens is
the dollar will continue to devalue over
time
and as more people want bitcoin the
value goes up its compounded annual
growth rates over 30
over the last uh almost 10 years or so
and so
ultimately what ends up happening is you
have these two financial systems you've
got a legacy
fiat system and you've got a digital
uh decentralized financial system
dollar is the core unit of account in
one side bitcoin is the core unit
account in the other side
the way that i have personally thought
about this is
i believe that there is a 50 50 chance
of both of these systems being the
winning system in the future
right so i personally again this is not
financial advice there is a lot of risk
you should go do your research but
because i have a 50 50 believe
in either system being the winner i have
chosen to split my net worth
put 50 in the fiat system and 50
in the digital decentralized system
there's a lot of people who say
ah i don't think there's a 50 50 chance
i think that there's a 99
chance that the fiat dollar system is
going to continue to serve as the global
reserve currency and the legacy finance
system will
prevail but there's a one percent chance
it's a non-zero percent chance that this
bitcoin
decentralized digital system could maybe
win it's very small
probability but it's possible one
percent
my my comment to those people is your
portfolio again not financial advice but
your portfolio should mimic what you
believe
so if you think it's 99 fiat one percent
bitcoin system well then you should go
99 the fiat system one percent the
bitcoin system
if you think it's 90 10 then go 90 10 if
you think it's 50 50 go 50 50.
like that is what people are are
understanding and that is what they're
getting educated on
is there's now two financial systems
with two different structures two
different designs
one punishes savers and rewards
investors
the rich get richer and the poor get
poor the other is a much more
equitable system where everyone who has
the currency simply needs to save
and it will continue to increase in
value because supply
and demand economics if you want to
understand bitcoin you have to
understand
regular economics 101 supply and demand
which is
you have a fixed supply asset 21 million
bitcoin if demand continues to increase
as it has for the last 11 years if
demand continues to increase
the u.s dollar value the price will
continue to increase over time that's
how supply and demand works
so that is what bitcoin is that's how it
works
that's why it's important and that's how
it fits in or compares to the macro
economy
i'm going to start taking questions here
in a second a couple of housekeeping
things
one please smash the like button so way
more people on youtube can see this
also make sure that you're subscribed to
the channel so you can see when i go
live and post other videos
and then i'm putting in the chat right
now i write a daily letter
to over 50 000 investors every single
morning go to pompletter.com again
pompletter.com pomp letter.com
and you can subscribe there and get the
letter i write about business technology
finance bitcoin
all kinds of different things all right
let's start with questions
i'm going to do the absolute best i can
there are there's over
2 000 people in here asking questions
and in here so i'm going to do whatever
i can to uh
to get through this yes i went 40
minutes without a breath
i actually have some wine here so if
anyone's got a drink uh well cheers
that's my first breath in 40 minutes all
right
uh how many bitcoin are lost forever so
obviously because
uh bitcoin works in a in a
cryptographically secure way right so
one of the things people need to
understand about bitcoin is the fact
that
when you put money um us dollars into
the bank the bank now owns
uh your dollars right that's not your
money anymore they give you an
iou they say you know you put a hundred
dollars and they say we owe you a
hundred bucks
but they take your dollars and they go
and they lend them out and they can lend
them out sometimes five six seven eight
times
and then they give you some interest in
exchange for you depositing it there but
that's not your
dollars anymore with bitcoin one of the
key
uh benefits or value propositions is
something called sovereignty
again all sovereignty is a big fancy
word it just means
you're in charge you're in control so
the whole idea with bitcoin is
you can hold the password
or the private key so in cryptography
the way cryptography works in a very
basic way
is there's a public key and a private
key
you need both the public key and the
private key to have control of the
bitcoin
right if somebody has your public key
they can't do anything with your bitcoin
if they get your private key similar to
a password they now can control your
bitcoin
so in the bitcoin system you can control
the private key which means you're in
charge
you're not reliant on a third party
right you're not reliant on a
centralized authority
you simply are in control and you have
sovereignty over your wealth
right i haven't ever said this in public
before but when we were in march
and all of a sudden there started to be
gyrations in the market
and there started to be a lot of
uncertainty in chaos i went to the bank
and i took dollars out right not because
i necessarily thought banks were going
to be insolvent i think it was a bank
crisis
but the fact that i knew that i had
counterparty risk with a bank a bank
could
all of a sudden say hey you can only
take out x dollars out of the bank or
you can't access your money today right
or they could say oh you can only spend
money at these locations or whatever it
was
but i wanted control i wanted
sovereignty i wanted peace of mind so i
went to the bank and i pulled money out
of it and so i took control of that cash
and i now had the sovereignty that's
because in the legacy system you
constantly are relying on somebody else
to
have custody of your money and control
and process your transactions
here in the bitcoin system you
constantly have those private keys
you're in control
so if you lose the private keys right
going back to this question
if you lose the private keys that means
that the bitcoin are lost
no one can get to them and so the
question is how many p
how many bitcoin have been lost i think
there's estimates of anywhere from a
million bitcoin to potentially as high
as 3 million
nobody knows for sure but there are
definitely
bitcoin that are lost there's 18.4
million bitcoin
that have been put into the circulating
supply already there are not 18.4
million bitcoin in the hands of people
people have definitely lost bitcoin
you can read stories online of you know
they lost 10 000 bitcoin or 50
000 bitcoin from early on or whatever so
i think that's a key piece to pay
attention to is
there's 21 million bitcoin in the total
supply but because some have been lost
it's actually effectively much less than
that so we'll see what that ends up
being
okay um what other questions what other
questions how would bitcoin become the
reserve currency all right so lots of
people always ask me you've got these
two systems
how do they compete with each other my
personal belief
is that every currency in the world is
going to be digitized over time
and what i mean by that is uh there's
going to be a digital dollar
a digital euro a digital yen a digital
one
a digital um you know uh boliviar
a digital lev all across the world every
currency that is in the fiat system is
going to be digitized
all that means is they're going to take
it and they're going to create a digital
version
of the exact same currency they have
today they're not going to change the
inflationary nature
they're not going to change the monetary
policy they're just going to change the
technology
if you go back you know 50 60 years we
used to have all paper money
there was no digi there was no kind of
electronic or digital
uh banking well now all there is so we
changed the technology form factor and
majority of the money like 92 93
is not physical money well now we're
gonna go through another transition
where everything is digital and really
that just means it's on some sort of
ledger whether that's public or private
it's on a ledger
and so in that situation you will have
the fiat currencies digitized
you will also get a ton of private
currencies
so you see facebook announced the libra
currency this is a corporation
creating a digital currency now they've
chosen to back theirs by
other fiat currencies jp morgan
announced jpm
coin which is another private currency
that's backed by a fiat currency
so you got fiat currencies digitized
you've got private currencies
and then what you're gonna have is
you're going to have bitcoin and bitcoin
is really
the first attempt or or the first
successful attempt in terms of market
share and adoption
to separate state and money it is saying
nobody controls this system it is
completely
uncontrolled and decentralized and
distributed
and so once every currency is digital
whether that's a fiat currency a
corporate currency
or a bitcoin the technology layer is the
same there's no competition there
everything's digital so what i believe
is going to happen is there's going to
be a competition at the monetary
policy level and at the monetary policy
level i laid out the difference between
the private currencies and the fiat
currencies which are inflationary in
nature
and the deflationary bitcoin so what i
believe the reason why i believe there's
a 50 50 chance is i actually have a very
high degree of confidence compared to
most people
that the superior monetary policy is one
that is
programmatic transparent and
deflationary now what do those three
things mean big words right
so programmatic simply means that
satoshi nakamoto who's the creator of
bitcoin it's a pseudonym
wrote into code exactly what the
monetary policy was
published the code anyone can go read
exactly what's going to happen
remember in the fiat system people are
still are still wondering
what is the federal reserve going to do
at the federal reserve meeting this week
we don't know there's people speculating
with billions of dollars in the markets
on what the federal reserve's going to
do we have
no clue right but in the bitcoin world
we can go look at the code and we know
it's programmatic
nobody can change it it's not up to
somebody's opinion um or kind of human
bias
it is written in code and that code
executes the code cannot be changed
unless majority of people agree to
change the code so programmatic the
second thing is transparent
we can see the code we can see every
transaction
and we can see every single bitcoin
that's being created and put into the
circulating supply
so you have a programmatic transparent
monetary uh
uh a monetary uh system right
we do not have that in the fiat world i
know more
about the bitcoins monetary um system
then you know about the fiat system
you don't know what the circulating
supply of the us dollar is
you don't know how many dollars were
printed today you don't know what the
next decision is going to be
and you can't show me every transaction
in history with bitcoin
i know exactly how many bitcoin are in
circulation
i know exactly how many are in the total
supply i know exactly how many
are being uh created today and i can
shoot every single transaction from
january third 2009 to today
but the beauty is you don't have to
trust me
i can prove to you i can show you
on the blockchain or in the database
exactly
in the code base exactly what it is you
can verify with your own eyes you don't
have to trust anybody
and so that is this why i believe
bitcoin's going to be the superior
monetary policy
now how do we go from where we are today
to
actually get to bitcoin being the global
reserve currency i believe it happens
over a long period of time
and it starts with people outside of the
united states right
people where the currency is failing so
venezuela zimbabwe
lebanon other places they begin to adopt
bitcoin
at the individual or the population
level because
it isn't controlled by anybody so if
your government just blew up the
currency through hyperinflation
they can't come to you and say oh our
bad we just gave you a bad currency but
here's our new currency you don't trust
them
so you're going to opt for a thing that
you know
can't be manipulated you know exactly
what it is you can verify it's
programmatic and transparent
now as that happens the at the
government
level bilateral trade today there's a
ton of negotiations that constantly go
on
if there's two countries and let's say
the united states isn't one of them so
china and russia
and they want to do a transaction those
two countries
try to figure out what currency are we
going to settle the transaction
should we use dollars should we use
rubles should we use rmb
what should we actually settle the
transaction but every country knows the
other countries are manipulating their
currency
the us is manipulating theirs they're
printing trillions of dollars other
governments are doing the same thing
so if you don't want to have to uh trust
another country and use their currency
and they don't want to trust you and use
your currency i believe that naturally
you're gonna start people to see
government saying in the next couple of
years why don't we just use bitcoin as a
settlement currency
we know that it's transparent
programmatic and it's not being
controlled by anybody or manipulated
we can just use that system and then now
all of a sudden we both agree that
that's a better system than either of
our currencies that are being
manipulated
so when you start to see bilateral trade
being settled i think that's going to be
a big moment
now there have been very small examples
of this in the past it was argentina did
two separate bilateral trades uh with
other countries they were very small
like tens of thousands of dollars or
hundreds of thousands of dollars
so they weren't big but bitcoin was used
to settle these transactions
i think that that will become much more
popular in the future the second piece
of bitcoin's rise to global reserve
currency and this is a very key piece
is bitcoin is going to rise to a global
reserve currency without
ever firing a bullet now what do i mean
by that
every single currency that was the
global reserve currency
uh before it was unseated had the
strongest military backing it
at some point they devalued the currency
enough where the economy was weakened a
another country came in they had violent
conflict they went to war
the new country won the war
they had the strong military they had
the strong economy and they said
we now are in charge and they put their
currency as the as the global reserve
currency
so there's always been when a global
reserve currency changes a transition
there's always been violent conflict in
the analog world
the person who is superior in a military
sense has always been the person with
the best offense
right and if you've got the best offense
you're the most powerful military
you get the global reserve currency but
that's in an analog world
in the digital world in cyber warfare
the strongest person
is actually the person with the best
defense if i can keep everybody
out i have the best defense i'm the
strongest person
right and so bitcoin all of the
computing power that is pointed at
bitcoin makes it the strongest computing
network in the world
it is the struct the bitcoin network is
the strongest computing network in the
world
and therefore i believe that in the
cyber world or in the digital world
bitcoin has the strongest military
right but they don't have any weapons
they're not offensive it's all defensive
because it's fully decentralized
distributed
and it's got the strongest computing
power behind it and in that world
what ultimately will happen is that i
think bitcoin is going to rise to the
global reserve currency
and be the first one to get there with a
all defense approach
to strength and it will never fire a
bomb a bullet
or kill anybody the conflict
is going to have bitcoin reigns supreme
because it's got the best defense the
strongest computing network it's fully
decentralized
you would have to have global
cooperation from
every country to shut bitcoin down you
would have to have every single
government get together
and say together 186 countries we're
going to shut it all down
it's not going to happen and so that's
where i believe
over time bitcoin ends up being the
global reserve currency
now that doesn't mean that every other
currency goes away
right today there are tens of if not 100
plus currencies in the world
and so it's not like because the dollar
became the global reserve currency
that all of a sudden all the other
currencies went away there's plenty of
countries that use a different currency
it's just that the dollar is the global
reserve and so just like we saw remember
what i went back to
when we saw the rise of the internet
everyone said in the beginning i don't
trust the internet
i don't know who the person i'm
transacting with is this is
weird i'm not used to doing this uh how
does this work
but now those businesses that went from
the analog world to the digital world
they ended up becoming much bigger
badder efficient
faster profitable than they ever were in
the analog world the internet
made them better and that's ultimately
what's happening with money
is the digital world is making money
better it's got a better monetary policy
it is able to be transacted
anywhere in the world and the defense
behind it is better than any military in
the world right there's no country that
can hack the bitcoin network
as far as we understand and so in that
world
i believe bitcoin will eventually rise
to be the global reserve currency that
may not happen for 50 or 100 years
right most currencies actually have a
pretty long run as a global reserve
currency
the dollar has been around for quite a
while but it doesn't mean that it's
going to happen tomorrow
what i do know though is that every
single currency that has failed in
history
has failed because the owner of the
currency has devalued it right
they've continued to produce or dilute
that money
and it's gotten less and less in value
and then eventually fails
that's what happens with fiat currencies
every single fiat currency is being
devalued
the dollar has lost 95 plus percent
of its purchasing power over the last
100 years
so naturally at some point history would
tell us that the dollar won't be the
global reserve currency right
i don't necessarily want that to happen
right i live in the united states
i grew up in a dollar-based system the
dollar works for me i can go to the
store and i can use dollars right this
isn't a kind of
uh statement as to um the dollar being
bad
as much as it is we just know if you
study history technology and investing
that the digital disruptor that is
better
and can get more distribution to a great
a greater number of people on the
internet
usually beats the analog world version
and i think that's what's going to
happen with bitcoin so
uh again i'll take a couple more
questions before i forget uh make sure
you
smash the like button some more people
on youtube will see this subscribe to
the channel
i'm putting pompletter.com in the chat
go subscribe i sent a daily letter 50
000 people every single day
and you can uh go there um okay
somebody's asking about what's gonna
happen to bitcoin moving forward
so this is really important in june of
2019
i wrote a thing for pumpletter.com where
i said
i believe three things are going to
happen in the future i believe that the
central bank is going to
bring interest rates down i didn't think
necessarily they'd go to zero but i
thought they're gonna have to
drastically bring them down
i think that they're going to have to
print a lot of money because we're
getting towards the end of a bull cycle
and when that happens and the and you
get the turnover of the economy and the
stock market
they're gonna say oh wait we're addicted
to stimulus let's create a bunch of
stimulus to get the economy going again
so you get rates drop you're gonna get a
bunch of printing of money
and i said those two things are going to
coincide
around the same time as the third
bitcoin having so that
1800 bitcoin per day that was getting
created uh each day
was going to drop to 900 that happened
in may well fast forward to earlier this
year
and those three things happened within
60 days of each other
we had two emergency interest rate cuts
that
cut all the way down to zero percent
interest rates we got
printing of trillions of dollars already
about 2.4 trillion dollars
many people think that we're gonna see
another two to three trillion dollars
in stimulus packages before we're out of
this the fed's balance sheet could reach
as high as 10 trillion dollars
right so you get interest rates to zero
you get trillions in quantitative easing
and the bitcoin having happened in may
in early may we went from 1800 to 900
bitcoin per day
and what i wrote about in june 2019 is
this is going to be
rocket fuel for bitcoin rocket fuel was
the terminology i used
why because the macro environment is
going to force people to look for
inflation hedge assets when you cut
rates and print money it leads to
inflation
and people are going to run out of the
dollar and dollar based things and
they're going to try to find inflation
hedge assets so it's going to be bullish
for
real estate gold silver and bitcoin but
bitcoin is the most volatile it's got
the smallest market cap it's only 200
billion dollar asset
and since it's so volatile that when all
of the assets go
up bitcoin will just go up more than the
rest of them right kind of volatility
goes up and down it's not good or bad
volatility when it goes against you
people don't like it because they lose
money but when volatility works in your
favor it's pointed in the right
direction
volatility is your friend because it
means that you're getting return right
you're going up in value
so i said rates are gonna go down
there's gonna be a bunch of printing of
money and we're gonna get the bitcoin
habit
all three of those things happen but not
only did they happen they happened at
much much greater scale than i could
have ever imagined
we have interest rates at zero we've
printed trillions of dollars
the bitcoin having occurred look right
now out of all of the asset classes
crypto has outperformed every single
asset class
in this recession so stocks are
basically flat
year to date gold is up 20 25
bitcoin is up more than 50 percent
bitcoin is up more than 50 in 2020 right
so what ends up happening is exactly
what i said
as you get that violent move upwards in
all asset classes because of the
inflation remember the dollar is being
devalued
asset prices rise rich get richer poor
get poorer
bitcoins just going to go up more than
the rest of them we've already seen that
playing out
i think over the next 18 months we're
going to continue to see that
and what ultimately happens go back to
supply and demand
the bitcoin having is a supply shock
right
1800 bitcoin used to be available every
day now there's only 900 that come
online
so that supply shock means if demand
stayed constant if demand didn't change
the price would naturally go up because
there's less of this available on a net
new basis
but instead of just having the supply
shock we also
had a demand shock because now they're
printing so much money
that people are saying wait a second i
got to go get out of the dollars and go
get into these inflation hedge assets
so you get a supply shock you get a
demand shock
and what i think that serves is this
rocket fuel that sends bitcoin's price
exploding upwards
it's up 50 so far this year it
includes it's up 50 since january 1st
that includes at one point it went down
50
so bitcoin has gone from
earlier this year all the way down to
about 3 800
and now is at 11 000 plus dollars
absolute
incredible upward volatility and it's
because the macro
environment is forcing investors to go
into bitcoin
this happened in 2008 2009 remember gold
went down 30
in 2008 during the liquidity crisis they
started printing lots of money
everyone ran to gold when they ran to
gold from 2009 to 2011
gold went up more than 200 percent and
it ended up hitting an all-time high
right now people are doing the same
thing they're printing tons of money
they're running to gold they're running
to bitcoin
right and when they do that you're
seeing those assets rise but
bitcoin is outperforming gold this year
by 2x so gold's up 25
bitcoins up over 50 and so that's going
to continue
because bitcoin is a much more volatile
asset just a smaller market cap of
course it's more
innovative disruptive new so it's going
to continue to go up so i think that's
what's going to happen
i'm publicly on record again not
financial advice there's risk
do your research all the normal
disclaimers right um
i believe that bitcoin is gonna hit a
hundred thousand dollars one hundred
thousand dollars u.s
by the end of december 2021. so
basically we're looking at we're in july
of 2020 right now
by the end of december 2021 i believe
bitcoin will hit a hundred thousand
dollars
people say that is absolutely ridiculous
but
what we see with bitcoin is bitcoin has
these big boom
and bust cycles and every time if you
bought at the bottom
of the last bus cycle and rode it
through the boom
and into the next bust that bus cycle
was always
higher than the previous low so it
continues to establish
higher lows and the reason why that's
important is those boom and bust cycles
are naturally how assets grow right and
so
bitcoin is likely to go from where it is
today
go all the way up to 100 plus thousand
dollars by the end of next year and then
it'll crash again
but when it crashes it's not gonna come
back to ten thousand dollars
it may crash to thirty forty fifty
thousand dollars
right it'll kind of go through another
multi-year barrel uh multi-year bear
market
and then it'll run again and it'll
continue to gain more and more value
if you believe that bitcoin is only a
store value it's not a medium of
exchange it's not money
you can't use it to buy things whatever
there's a lot of people who believe that
and it's just a store of value right
like gold
today bitcoin's market cap is 200
billion
gold is seven or eight trillion dollars
so let's just use eight trillion dollars
as the number
if bitcoin reaches gold's market cap
that means that bitcoin would 40 x
to get to gold's market cap think about
that for a second
the analog store of value versus
the digital store value if you think
that bitcoin can hit the same store or
the same market cap as gold
that means that the bitcoin price would
have to go up 40 x to get there
right pretty crazy when you start
thinking about it i
personally believe that bitcoin is not
just a store of value
it's actually money and so when you
think of bitcoin as
money then you say what is the global
monetary supply
the global money supply is somewhere in
the 70 to 90 trillion dollars depending
on how you count
so that means let's take 80 trillion as
the easy number
that means that bitcoin if it was to go
from a 200 billion dollar asset
and reach 80 trillion dollars which is
the global money supply so kind of
match the money supply there would be a
400 x increase in bitcoin's price
again very very small chance that this
happens
but that's what the numbers would show
you to go from a 200 billion dollar
asset to an 80 billion
or to an 80 trillion dollar asset right
it's kind of showing you how small
bitcoin is
but i actually believe that not only is
bitcoin
money it is a market expanding
type of money what do i mean by that
when uber was a startup and they were
pitching people they would say
we are going to try to disrupt the taxi
industry
sounds pretty cool but when you look at
the taxi industry it's really not
that big and so if you simply just said
okay uber's here
and they're going to try to disrupt the
taxi industry that means that uber can
you know 20 to 30 x not a bad return but
it's not
insane type returns right it's not
multi-billion dollar company type
returns
and so that would have been a fair
assessment but what actually happened is
uber ended up
not only beating the taxi industry it
ended up expanding
into other areas and now it's a ride
sharing company
so it beat the taxis it beat the black
cars
it also beat car ownership there's many
people who don't own a car
because they use uber and so this market
expanding technology means that it
actually was
bigger addressable market than people
originally realized
right airbnb is another example if you
said hey airbnb
is simply going to be a competitor to
hotels you would look at the total
addressable market of hotels
but airbnb is different airbnb competes
with all
different types of logic you may
actually say ah i don't even want a
hotel
in my own city i just want to rent an
airbnb so that i can go have an event
there and then come back to my house
tonight
and so it's a market expanding
technology and so it's a much more
it's much bigger adjustable market than
just hotels bitcoin is the same thing in
my opinion
it is not just competing with gold or
competing with the money supply
it's actually got the possibility to be
much bigger than that now how does that
work
murad mahav did came on on the podcast
that i run
uh and he gave a great um kind of
breakdown of this and basically what
murad said is
go back to what the dollar incentivizes
people to do get out of the dollar and
get into store value assets
so take your dollars and buy our real
estate precious metals stocks etc
well if all of a sudden the currency the
global reserve currency
ends up being able to uh be bitcoin to
be
and it's this deflationary system now
you aren't financially incentivized to
get out of the currency
now you can just hold bitcoin and when
you do that what you'll do is you
actually steal
market share back from those store value
assets so you will steal market share
back from art
from real estate from precious metals
from all these other assets
you'll simply be a saver the fiat system
rewards investors and punishes savers
the bitcoin system rewards savers
and in this system if it can grow
and have global adoption become a global
reserve currency now all of a sudden it
will steal market share and so you're
not talking about just getting to
80 trillion dollars the number that
murad used was a 150 trillion dollar
market
cap right it would start pulling back
all of uh the market cap from these
other assets
now i'm not smart enough to do the math
on a 150 trillion
so let's just simply use 160 because
that's double 80 trillion
in that case 400 x would be from 200
billion to 80 trillion
well that means it's 80 800 x from 200
billion
to uh a 160 trillion dollar market cap
now i'm not claiming that it's going to
go to 150 160 trillion dollars
but that is the way to kind of look at
the growth trajectory it's a 200 billion
dollar asset
it could grow to gold's market cap which
would be 8 trillion
it could grow the global money supply
would be about 80 trillion or it could
grow and actually be a market expanding
technology
and grow to 150 160 trillion so you
would be looking at
40x 400x 800x again i don't know what's
going to happen
i believe that there is a 50 50 chance
between the fiat system
and this digital decentralized system
i'm 32 years old
i'm young i've got a very high risk
tolerance i understand that i could lose
the 50 that i put in the bitcoin system
right so whatever you invest you can
lose
so you have to be careful you have to do
your own research all of the normal
disclaimers
but i'm willing to take that risk
because i believe
50 50. right you've got to figure out
what do you believe 99
1 90 10 whatever it is that's what you
got to do all right
i'm going to answer two more questions
and then i got uh things i need to go do
i need to plug this in
so that my computer doesn't die um
uh
let's see what other questions what
other questions do you think that
bitcoin will always lead the way in
terms of value if there's a better
technology such as litecoin
okay so what about all the other
cryptocurrencies is basically what this
question's asking
there's lots of people who uh who ask
this question
and what i always go to is two key
things there's about
5 000 crypto assets right i use
assets for a very specific work there's
three types of crypto assets there's
crypto
currencies these are cryptographically
secure
digital assets that are trying to be
money right so cryptocurrency
there are utility tokens which basically
are things that give you
access to a network a product a service
think of this this could be like um you
know tokens at an arcade or
or something like that um or there are
kind of the security or investment
assets right so this is like taking the
equity of a company and digitizing it or
tokenizing it
so there's cryptocurrencies there's
utility tokens and then there's kind of
these tokenized securities
there's actually a very small number of
them that are trying to be currencies
right of the 5 000 there might be 15 or
less that are trying to be money
and in there the market has determined
this isn't my opinion the market has
determined
that bitcoin is far and away the winner
right could that change sure anything's
possible
but going back to what is money money is
a belief system
and when you have belief in a network
and there's
tens of millions of people who have all
bought in money is a very
viral product right we send it back and
forth and people get locked into the
network effects
right so think of the dollar if you use
the dollar you probably don't use
another currency you just use the dollar
you're locked into that system
everything's priced in dollars everyone
accepts dollars right you have dollars
you're paid in dollars you get locked in
the system
in the bitcoin system there's tens of
millions of people who've adopted it and
they're getting locked into this system
and so in order for something to um
unseat bitcoin
as the king in the cryptocurrency uh
vertical you would need that
belief to break down and for something
else to capture the belief
i personally do not believe that's gonna
happen and it goes back to the same
example like when venezuela's bolivia
fails the government comes back and says
oh sorry our bad we have this other
currency now that you should try our
second one
nobody believes them i think that's what
happened
in a decentralized um digital currency
bitcoin is the one attempt to separate
state and money
and to have a decentralized uh
distributed um
kind of system right or deflationary
digital currency
if it doesn't work nobody's gonna trust
the next one
right it's got too much market share
it's got too much adoption at this point
too many people would get hurt and those
people happen to be the early adopters
for this type of technology
that if it actually didn't work the next
one that came along
everyone would be we saw that already it
didn't work and so the only thing that
you could do
is you would have to wait for those
people to literally die
and then somebody could try it again but
i don't think that anything
if bitcoin doesn't work i don't think
there will be a decentralized digital
currency
so it's basically bitcoin or nothing in
the currency vertical
now the other call it you know 4
900 plus currencies that are out there
there's all kinds of debate what's
valuable what's not valuable i'm not
going to cover that stuff now
but those aren't trying to be currencies
and so it's really important to kind of
break off in the crypto world what's
trying to be a currency bitcoin's the
winner
uh the market's determined that and i
don't think that's going to change
anytime soon
um okay uh usability of bitcoin so this
is another thing that people always ask
about
which is um bitcoin is quote unquote
slow right is something that's people
will say if you look at the fiat system
gold was the layer one right so we had
gold and gold was
hard to transact it wasn't divisible
it's hard to move around it wasn't
portable all that kind of stuff
what we did was we took gold and we said
we're gonna put it in a vault
and then we're gonna create a paper
claim on that gold a layer two
so now you can just walk around with
these pieces of paper and spend those
and we know that it's backed by
the gold that's sitting in the vault
then we built on top of that
electronic money on top of the paper
money easier to transact
and then we even built credit and other
things on top so there's kind of
multiple layers to the fiat
or the dollar system started with gold
and then went paper claims
digital money and all the way up that's
what's happening with bitcoin
so gold was super secure super provable
you could have sovereignty of it all of
these things bitcoin is the exact same
the transactions get processed batched
together every 10 minutes like we talked
a block chain a chain of blocks of
transactions every 10 minutes
so people will say oh it's slow but
think of it as a spectrum
between you can have speed or you can
have security
bitcoin just like gold in the dollar
system has chosen for layer one
to optimize for security it is much more
important to be secure
at layer one than it is to be fast and
so by being secure
what you're now seeing is we're already
building layer two which is
you might hear something called the
lightning network or other things and so
that layer two
is similar to the paper claims on the
gold it's a little bit easier
to carry around and move it's a little
bit cheaper it's a little bit faster
it's a little bit more efficient
that's exactly what layer two does layer
two is built on top of layer one
and it makes it more efficient to spend
and use bitcoin there will be a layer
three a layer four etc on top of it
and so over time it will become much
much easier to use
it will become faster more efficient
cheaper all of these things
but going back money is the most
important asset in the world
right just like gold had to be the super
secure
sovereign asset at layer one the bitcoin
network as is designed
had to be the super secure sovereign
asset at layer one in this new system
and then you'll get the additional
layers on top of it we're only 11 years
into this
right this is a multi-decade rise
to become the next global reserve
currency and so i think that's what
people really have to understand here is
this is not just about how fast is it
today how shiny is something today how
innovative and all that kind of stuff
it's all about you have to be very
methodical very safe
very secure and very intentional about
what you're building
because today there's 200 billion
dollars uh in value at stake
if bitcoin was to be blown up right in
terms of a self-inflicted wound there
was a bug introduced in the code
something like that
there'd be 200 billion dollars of value
that would uh dissipate or disappear and
evaporate
and so in that situation security safety
methodical intentional work is the most
important thing that's what bitcoin's
doing i actually think it's doing
exactly what it needs to do
so uh all right i'm gonna take one more
question before i do that
go smash the like button so we get more
people on youtube to watch this
i'm trying to get a hundred 000
subscribers we're really close so make
sure you're subscribed to the channel
i'm gonna put pompletter.com again
pompeompletter.com
i just dropped the link in the chat go
click on it sign up for the daily letter
that i write to uh
50 000 investors every single day and
um let's see all right i've seen
somebody put in here a million times
lengthening cycles yes so this last
question i'm going to answer lengthening
cycles basically is this idea that those
boom and bust cycles i talked about
they continued to get longer in timeline
so in the beginning it might have been
you know a six month boom cycle
and a uh i don't know nine month bus
cycle and then it would be a 12 month
boom cycle then an 18-month
bus cycle right and each time the boom
and bus gets longer and longer
what it really is doing is not only is
it lengthening in time
but it's also getting less volatile and
the reason is because more and more
people are adopting it
so if you think back to um till ray
which was a marijuana stock that got
floated
i think it was in canada and it exploded
in fact i mean this thing went up like
hundreds of percent everyone was
freaking out
the reason is because they took all of
the stock for the company
and they only floated a little bit i
don't remember what it was one or two
percent
and there were so many people that
wanted it but there was only one or two
percent of the stock available
and so because there was this frenzy in
demand the price exploded
but the company and the and the
directors and employees held most of the
stock back
right so there wasn't that much float
well in the early days of bitcoin
the first 10 minutes there was only 50
bitcoin in circulating supply
then after 20 minutes there was only 100
after 30 minutes there was only 150.
so it was very slow in terms of putting
it into circulating supply
fast forward 11 years now there's 18.4
million bitcoin in circulating supply
so there's been a dilution or more
liquidity in the market
right so that lowers the volatility
because there's more liquidity
there's also been uh in the beginning
there's only a couple of people using
bitcoin now there's tens of millions of
people using bitcoin
and on top of all of that you start to
see
that there is a very very high
percentage of bitcoin that hasn't moved
in long periods of time right what we
call strong hands
if you believe a deflationary asset is
going to continue to get more valuable
over time
why would you spend it you're gonna get
it and you're gonna hold it
and when people hold it that ends up
being
a floor for the price so when you get
these boom and bust cycles
there's some percentage of bitcoin that
don't move right call i don't know 50
of bitcoin haven't moved in like five
years or some crazy number like that i
don't remember the exact number
in those situations you get a
lengthening of the time you get less
volatility
and ultimately you get a continued
increase in price right like i said 30
um compound annual growth rate so that's
basically what happens with
uh with this all right i've gone for
more than an hour and 15 minutes i
promised plane i was only gonna go for
an hour
so i'm in trouble now which means i'm
gonna get the hell out of here
uh go smash the like button please
please please let's get more people
watching this stuff
more people need to be educated learn
about bitcoin learn about the economy
make sure you subscribe to the channel
pompletter.com
i just put it in the chat go subscribe
and i will try to do these more often
i appreciate all of you coming here to
watch this and
have a great night